c'est mon coup de gueule c'est un
sondage qui a été fait pour le magazine
marianne un sondage qui demande aux
français qu'elle est pour eux la
définition de la tenue correcte exigée
vous savez que c'est un débat qui agite
la toile ont de la tenue correcte exigée
que devrait avoir les jeunes si pour
aller au lycée
alors évidemment ça fait hurler les
jeunes filles qui disent on s'adresse
voilà donc moi ce sondage
personnellement il me fait gerber c'est
vrai il est surréaliste parce que on
devrait dire aux jeunes filles et
qu'elles n'ont pas le droit d'aller à
l'école sans soutien-gorge qu'elles
n'ont pas le droit d'aller à l'école
avec un recours alors excusez moi on est
dans une période où on a le droit de
rien faire alors la seule liberté qui
nous restent justement nous les femmes
c'est pouvoir s'habiller un peu comme on
veut non mais moi je trouvais ce sondage
il est un âge alors c'est quoi la tenue
s'il vous plaît est ce qu'on va voir à
la tenue regarder mais regarder les
dessins voilà à regarder les dessins
donc voilà c'est ça ouais non mais ça
c'est pas possible
descendez bien faire oui non mais c'est
clair que je suis contre totalement ce
sondage mais après ce que tu dit
francesca tu dis les jeunes filles
doivent être libres de s'habiller comme
elle veut non pas du tout je suis pas
d'accord avec toi pour dire ses deux
fils et pour quels motifs parce que
quand on est haut que ce soit en
primaire au collège ou non pas au lycée
parce qu'après il glissé la moline c'est
le lycée est bien le lycéen à quel âge
on a 17 ans 16 ans car aujourd'hui dans
deux ans je suis désolé à ce moment là
soit on remet l'uniforme c'est ça que je
trouve un peu hypocrite ce genre de
choses sont remis l'uniforme montceau
demande aux gens d'avoir du bon sens ce
à dire que les jeunes filles qui vont
s'habiller en croque top et en mini jupe
au lycée à l'om mais alors pourquoi
très bien répond string à l'école kebab
a essayé banon à pourvoir y aura une
différence pour les garçons et les
filles de l'élan giro qu'il faudrait
couper que vous me laissant délégation
est au bout de ce que je pense mais
n'est pas les aimer ça fait deux heures
là c'est exactement la même chose et les
garçons ils viennent en tenue décente
oui je suis désolé on respecte les
professeurs on respecte le cadre de
l'école et on vient pas arriver et c'est
normal j'ai quitté une rtt coup de tes
parents et a du bon sens et qu'elle
gardait alors c'est son avis je pense
qu'il faut plutôt changer le regard des
garçons sur l'infime ça la chanson elle
pas que des garçons et des filles lalem
pas aussi les garçons il s'habille
genres et les habitent tous normalement
ce que je voudrais bien sûr le sondage
c'est que c'est un sondage de l'institut
ifop ifop qui a proposé à plusieurs
médias qu'en dit non les rédactions se
sont réunis ils ont refusé pour quels
motifs et mariama parce qu'il trouvait
justement très sexy et discriminant
vraiment marianne a eu tort marianne qui
parfois verse un peu dans le crash alors
de la team nsa vois pas pourquoi mais je
barre ils ont fait parler d'eux ben oui
alors voilà c'est uniquement pour ça
mais faire parler d'eux en critiquant de
manière sexiste les filles moi ça me
révolte
non non si la mère noël
moi je suis contente que ce soit la plus
jeune oui les boules justement je suis
contente que ce soit la plus jeune
qu'elle aime les propos de plus de bon
sens presque et qu'est ce qu'on faisait
nous quand on était au lycée nous on
avait envie d'avoir des jus pour a de la
joie de vivre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et au lycée bas ont baissé et pour moi
il m'est arrivé au lycée qu'on me disait
mademoiselle fermer votre soutien
lorsque rien à montrer mais j'ai
toujours ouverts sur mes bâtons et
barres me disait fermer un peu et donc
je fermais mon passager pitch de loups
prêts quand je sortais du nord dans les
établissements privés et de rêver de
jean-michel feu de gamme
oui j'essaie pour les garçons quand même
il exagérait parce que mon fils en 4e
ils n'avaient pas droit de m de short
parce que soi-disant les poils exciter
les filles n'ont maintenant moi je
voudrais sûr que leur école privée
interdit les chambres mais l'amour sans
[Rires]
nom je oui c'est quasi générale non mais
là c'est n'importe quoi il faut arrêter
d'interdire les gens ils font ce qu'ils
veulent c'est le chantage à la con à la
6e place et la soupe le bâtiment est
quand même le moins bien dhabi je
remercie pour l'intérêt de ce sondage
et puis regardez ces pictogrammes des
courriers de la réalité c'est le
pictogramme sens à tout ça c'est du
travail alors viendrait surtout pas et
en fait il voulait amasser le mot
pictogrammes tout cela viendrait pas à
l'idée de faire un sondage sur
l'habillement des jeunes garçons base
toujours sur les filles sont les garants
focalise le truc ils ont cédé leurs
titres à venir
s'habiller comme elles le souhaitent et
là on sera très bien ce nom mais on a
quand même
non mais comme elle le souhaite mais
c'est bien tu es bon sens l'état des
petits de 14 ans aime bien le bon sens
et c'est normal c'est des enfants non il
faut avoir un bon sens et coop
académique comme elle le souhaite
six mois vont arriver à poil c'est une
question de casting marcheurs pour
l'institution parce que si on fait ce
qu'on veut a soit b mais je m'aligne un
chewing gum pendant l'école tu décroches
ton téléphone
oui mais de dignité mais comment ça va
péter ont placé toute façon c'est
l'éducation des parents si oui mais par
on attend attendez je te le gist
j'aimerais avoir l'avis de richard
richard du bar de la plage de la leçon
que ça complètement débile parce que
regarder mais ambitieuse mais ne t'en ai
regardé bon l'autre graphismes étaient
mieux là je vois mal le nombril pas
celui-là le nombre est sûr ne pas
pleurer michel pour sa mise en ligne de
son rocher
oui alors ouais c'est n'importe quoi un
tee shirt on voit laisser apparaître les
bretelles du soutien-gorge d'être fou le
nombre il faut pas le voir le téton au
taux de soutien gorge à travers duquel
le prêt on a le droit moi je suis comme
gilles mais ça gêne qu'il a ça gêne pas
les professeurs sa gêne que les mecs qui
se font des filles dans leurs pertes
chez les mecs il faut éduquer jean il
avait la garde
on fait quoi en fait plus rien un
nombril on a toujours moi quand j'étais
au lycée j'ai jamais toulis et quand
j'étais au collège quand est-on
maternelle
mais pour ça je suis pas fou mais ça a
toujours été ça on se réveille on dit ça
on est tous en train de te dire que le
on n'est pas d'accord avec ce truc là on
est en train de te dire pour les
ferrière dois tu dis que ça va vite où
sony j'étais jeune et que je suis contre
ce sondage parce que les naissances ont
pourri c'est nul mais par contre je suis
pour le fait d'avoir du bon sens et de
s'habiller normalement tu peux montrer
ton nombril 100 m environ
il ya des façons fois ci c'est vulgaire
mathieu clément garde ce qu'il a un avis
là-dessus clément mais moi ça fait pas
si longtemps que j'étais au collège et
je sais que j'étais dans un collège
privé évidemment il y avait un cadre et
je pense qu'au bout d'un an il faut
accepter le cadre dans lequel oui on est
instruit il ya des collèges et des
lycées qui interdisent des choses pour
les accepter
on est dans une société en 2001 j'ai
l'impression quand on refuse tout ce
qu'on use in tout ce qu'on nous inculque
et le sondage a lui-même mois les
dessins me choque
oui mais après je pense qu'il faut
accepter les cadres dans lequel on est
précieux points là où stagnent à la 12e
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
simplement pardon ma femme forcée à
mettre un soutif
moi je fais à 1,75 à j'aurais pas aimé
qu'on embête au lycée et confort ça va
être un soutien gorge si j'ai envie de
mettre un débardeur ça veut pas dire que
les gens malheureusement pas assez de
bon sens du but pour laisser leurs
enfants habillés normalement les copines
au collège
prenez leur maquillage et l aller se
changer aux toilettes et mettre du
maquillage en secret de leurs parents
non ça le problème c'est que je suis une
touche à ce que c'est vrai
isabelle à l'époque ça vous dire quant à
l'arrivée en culottes courtes à l'école
et puis on va parler sur les mots tu
mets une petite brassière saïd chef
coupe le chef mais pas de couper le chef
du groupe et chez lui va pas c est
seulement parce que je dire on n'est pas
au marxisme et de jeu vous envoyer aux
marchés le mage arrière se régaler les
deux dira coupe on dirait qu'ils ont une
caravane les deux non non non je parlais
de rien et on embrasse bien sûr tous mes
amis